revealing your identity right now why
are you doing that and why haven't you
before
so
the reality is that I think most Twitter
accounts are Anonymous to start with
unless you're a public official or you
know a figure unless you have the
verification well not anymore yeah but
until Elon changed that you know most
most Twitter accounts start off
Anonymous as as did mine
and then
I you know when my account started
growing I realized the hatred
um that the left has and their violent
nature and I was like I'm going to
remain anonymous yes as my account was
growing and getting more effective
um and I have remains Anonymous until
now well until I was I was docs my name
was shared my location was shared my my
photo was never shared though I've never
done any in-person events and I'm
choosing to do that now because
I feel like I over the past few months
I've done so much I've helped educate
people I know that I I have helped
create legislation to tackle some of
these issues and
um I I think I've done all I can and I
am ready for the next step I get people
asking me I have Mom groups asking me
all the time can you come help us
I got invitations you know to to help to
help people understand how to how to
expose the left and how to fight it and
you know being anonymous was sort of
keeping me like I was restrained from
from doing all those things and I I'm
ready to do that I think that I'll be a
lot more effective when I'm not so
Anonymous anymore and I'm excited I
already have a couple of speaking
engagements planned for the next few
months good and you know hopefully there
will be more but I want to do while I
can and and help people
to fight this agenda and I'm glad that
you are I think it's an act of Bravery
and you've had a remarkable effect and I
just want to say and I'll say this
another 10 times because I think it's
the most interesting part about you
you haven't really editorialized very
much what you've done essentially is
bring to light or bring to further light
to publicize what they're already saying
in public that's your crime yeah exactly
they don't they don't want it to be
shown though to a certain audiences they
they want their their content out there
but but they don't want us to see it so
it doesn't really add up
no it doesn't add up and they have no
valid complaint against you right you
haven't violated anyone's privacy you're
posting what they put on Tick Tock
they're allowed to post it but we're
just not going to notice the crime is
noticing what they're doing yes that's
always the crime yeah
um so I think you've done an amazing
thing and unlike so many other people in
journalism and I'm gonna whether you
like it or not describe you as being a
journalism because I think you are I
think I am too
um you've had an effect a real effect by
bringing this to light how did you wind
up I mean to the extent you're
comfortable sharing it like how did you
wind up doing this you I assume you went
to Columbia journalism school to become
a journalist I went to Harvard and Yale
um thank God I didn't know because those
are now obviously those institutions
were all poisoned
um but so it started really during covid
um I was noticing all of this content
that was being published on Tick Tock um
and I was just like this is crazy like
but at this point you're not in a
related field like you were no
you're not doing anything related to
public policy or journalism nothing
related to politics journalism now maybe
were you very political no
really I was not because it was like the
other day this was a couple years ago
yeah this was two years ago well my
account started two years ago yeah
that's that that's just incredible you
can have this effect this quickly so
you're not a super political person
you're not watching People's speeches on
C-Span no no you're just a normal person
stuck inside exactly and then and then
covet happened and and I think that
covid
um for me and and I think for a lot of
people it really woke people up
um and it was sort of it was like an
Awakening
um either you can
stay
um like sleeping you know not really
interested in what's going on in our
government or you can choose to get to
get involved and I think covet really
drew a lot of people in just because of
all of the insanity that was going on
and that was being imposed on us our
rights were being violated
um and I was like and that was really uh
that was really a turning point for me
um to to get involved and to be
interested and then
um covet also is when Tick Tock started
becoming big because everyone was stuck
at home looking for entertainment and
then they stumbled on Tick Tock and we
started seeing all those videos of of
nurses you know dancing in hospitals
during during the pandemic and I was
like you know Tick Tock was was getting
really big and I was like oh you know
let me let me see what this Tick Tock
thing is all about and then I I stumbled
upon this whole
um this whole platform with with all of
I mean all of the stuff you know
everyone I'm sure has seen some of the
videos it's just there's so much more
and I was like I just I need to
disseminate this like this it's this
it's just so bizarre and and dangerous
and I was like I just need as many
people to see this as possible and in in
large part not exclusively but there was
a lot of adults bragging about
sexualizing children yes a lot
specifically teachers they're also just
parents activists doctors
um that is the most scary part about it
and that's what my count focuses on a
lot now
gosh what what an interesting
conversation I hope her stepping out
inspires others to do this to do the
same step out and speak the truth you
can stream Tucker's full conversation
with higher Rachel right now on Fox
Nation
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight